حكومه بوركينا فاسو رسميا القوات الفرنسيه
الموجوده على اراضيها بمغادرتها في غضون
شهد وقالت السلطات في وجدوكو ان الامر لا
يتعلق بقطع علاقاتها مع باريس ويقتصر فقط
على اتفاقات التعاون العسكري وتشد البلاد
منذ اشهر مظاهرات تطالب برحيل القوات
الفرنسيه ملتهمه اياها بان وجودها لم يحسن
الامن في وجه ما تصفه باللهجمات الارهابيه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم كان هناك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي حيثياته ودوافع
قرار بوركينا فاسو القاضي برحيل جميع
الجنود الفرنسيين المتمركزين الشرقيه
العاصمه وجدوكو ومنحهم شهرا واحدا
المغادره وكيف استقبل التاريخ بنظري
انعكاساته على التحديات الداخليه
والخارجيه التي يواجهها ماكرون ما هي ما
الالات الوجود الفرنسيه في دول الساحل
والصحراء وفي افريقيا عموما على ضوء
انسحابات عسكريه سابقه من تلك المنطقه كما
حدث في مالي سيف العام الماضي وكيف نربط
تراجع نفود الفرنسي في افريقيا مع خريطه
القوى الدوليه الفاعله في القاره
[موسيقى]
هي مرحله متقدمه لحاله التوتر التي سادت
العلاقات بين بوركينا فاسو وفرنسا في
الاونه الاخيره ففي محطات عده تصاعدت
الانتقادات التي سرعان ما تحولت الى
احتجاجات على الدوري الفرنسي في ما يتعلق
بالوضع الامني في البلاد وصل الامر لحد
المطالبه برحيل القوات الفرنسيه
المرابطه في ضواحي العاصمه وجدوكو على
واقع هجمات متتاليه تعرضت لها العاصمه وفي
ظل مؤشرات على ان السلطات البوركينابيه
ترغب في التوجه اكثر نحو روسيا بحثا عن
تعاونا انجح من وجهه نظرها في مواجهتها
تصفه بالهجمات الارهابيه التي تتهم القوات
الفرنسيه بالتقصير في مواجهتها بل ويهمس
غاضبون من سياسات باريس بانها تتواطئ معها
[موسيقى]
ولك شو الموضوع مع ضيفينا من باريس باتريك
فور سي الخبير في شان الافريقي ومن وان
شوت الهيبه ولد الشيخ سيداتي الصحفي
المختص في شمال افريقيا
خلال شهر واحد
في الحقيقه
الى هذا البيان الصادر عن بوركينا فاسو
طبعا هناك
ترقد كان هناك ترقد لقرار مماثل لانه في
شهر نوفمبر وزير الدفاع الفرنسي كان قد
لحظه ان هناك عمليه سابر
والتي هي العمليه التي تشارك فيها القوات
الخاصه الفرنسيه في بوركينا فاسو منذ
العام 2011 اشار الى ان هذه العمليه قد
تتوقف بنظري الى قرارات الحكومه في وجدوده
وبالتالي منذ 15 يوما
الوزير وزير خارجيه زار
همم الرئيس
الرئيس الجديد
وهو المسؤول عن مستقبل بوركينا فاسو
للتناقشي معه في هذه الامور ولم يتم اتخاذ
اي قرار هل هناك ولكن نحن نشاهد البيان
البيان ليله امس قد صدر ورسميا بوركينا
فاسو تطالب بخروج القوات الفرنسيه عن
اراضيها نتحدث عن 400 جندي ليس بالعدد
الكبير ولكن نتحدث بالضبط عن القوات
الخاصه الفرنسيه
كيف ترى الاتهامات الموجه للقوات الفرنسيه
العامله في بوركينا فاسو
بالتقصير في مواجهه ما تصفها السلطات
بالهجمات الارهابيه ايضا هناك من يشير الى
تواطئ فرنسي مع عادل امام
حتى لا استخدم مصطلحات تقصير او التواطؤ
يمكن بشكل واضح وجلي ان نستخدم مصطلحات
تخادم فعلا هناك تخادم حصل مع الوجود بين
القوات الفرنسيه ووجودها في نسخها
المختلفه من برخان سرفالي صابر مع هذه
القوى ومع هذه جماعات العسكريه المسلحه في
منطقه غرب افريقيا في شمال مالي وبلغه
الارقام وبلغه الاكثر تحديدا فرنسا تدخلت
في حدود في العام 2011 عسكريا على بالوجود
في شمال مالي حينها كانت الجماعات
الموسيقى على الشمال محدوده توصف حين هذه
انها القاعده بعض المقاتلين وجيوب قليله
جدا من من همم
همم تنظيم الدوله
تسيطر على الشمال المالي في تيمبو فوق
شمالا لكنها بعد كل هذه الفتره من التدخل
الفرنسي همم الجماعات اصبحت اا موجوده في
الوسط المالي في بوركينا فاسو ازدادت هذه
الجماعات ازداد عددها اتسعت رقعه عملياتها
الجغرافيه لتجمل حتى ساحل العاج وبركنا
فاسو وتشاد والنيجر هناك تخادم واضح وجديد
سببه هذا التخادم في وجهه نظري ان فرنسا
دخلت في عمليه الهلى
اهداف محدده وواضحه ومن التقسيمه عن شمال
الماضي وربما نجحت نسبيا في هذا التدخل
لكنها حين غيرت الاسم وغيرت الاهداف الى
همم همم تغيرت الى عمليه مفتوحه من حيث
الزمن لم يكن هناك هدف محدد لهذه العمليه
وبالتالي حكم عليها بانها استعمار شديد في
المنطقه ثانيا اتسعت لم تعد مقصوره او
مختصره على مالي فحولتها الى شبه المنطقه
لو سمحت
فرنسا والقوات الفرنسيه في هذه الهجمات
باقتضاب لو سمحت
استخدمت انها تتخادمه هناك فعلا تخادم بين
هذه القوى القوى الموجوده
الفرنسيه ومظاهر ذلك معروفه الان القوى
الملاحظه لها في غرب افريقيا تقوم على
مرتكزات ثلاثه واربعه ترى هذه القوى
النفاثات مكابره في الاستعمار تكاد تكون
الدوله الوحيده التي تكابر في استعمالها
لا تعتذر عنه ترفض وجوده وترفضوا عندنا
اعتراف بماضها السيئ في افريقيا وبنات
الثروات وبي- همم ماضي انتهاك حقوق
الانسان ترفض حتى مجرد الحديث وفتح الحديث
عن هذه الثاني هو سياسه شديد سياسات همم
الهجره على الشعوب على المواطنين الافارقه
الذين يرون
باريس
كيف ترى هذه الاتهامات
الامور بالنسبه الى مصطلح التواطئ ابدا به
المصطلح قوي للغايه هو ومبلغ
نتحدث عن 60 جنديه فرنسيه
الارهابيه المتواجده في تلك المنطقه
وبالتالي لا اعتقدوا ان القوات الفرنسيه
المتواطئه طبعا انا متاكد من ان القوات
الفرنسيه لن تتواطئ مع العدو وهذا تحليل
غير مستند الى اسس
اوكي اوكي لانه ذكر ذكر لك السيد الهيبه
ذكر بان اعداد من يوصفون بالمجموعات
الارهابيه تزايد في هذه المنطقه بالتالي
هل هناك تقصير من هذه القوات
هذه حقيقه هذا واقع
نتحدث عن عمليتين سوفال وهي عمليه
محدده وهي ادت الى وقفي المد الجهاديه من
الشمال وبعد ذلك اتت العمليه الثانيه التي
لربما كانت خطا
وقضت ب- تبقى القوات الفرنسيه في مالي
لمساعده الحكومه الفرنسيه الماليه لكي
تستعيد الحكومه الماليه دورها ولكي تؤدي
الدوري المطلوب منها من حيث المدارس
والزراعه الى اخره لكي يكون هناك دوله ذات
سياده في مالي
ولكن ظهرت مشكله الحكم وظهرت مشكله الفساد
بعد ذلك في مالي
وهذا لم يساعد على تحسين الوضع باضافه الى
ذلك القوات الماليه الجيش المالي كان لديه
في الكثير من المشاكل بنسبه الى مواجهه
الاتجار بالاسلحه لقد شاهدنا تفكنا لي
المشهد السياسي المالي على مر السنوات
وبعد ذلك شاهدنا انقلاب
ووضحت هذه النقطه السيد باتريك اسمح لي
السيد الهيبه قبل ان انتقل الى المحور
الثاني هل يمكن حصر الاحتجاجات في بوركينا
فاسو وفي وجدوكو تحديدا ومتلاها من قرارات
بانها همم سقط وغضب شعبي فقط
لا هذه الاحتجاجات لها جذور تاريخيه
وابعاد واقعيه في دور التاريخيه ان
بوركينا فاسو كانت تحين الى ثوره توماس
الذي قاد ثوره للمعسكر الشرقي في 800 قال
الماضيه وعملا انقلابا يعتبر ثوري افريقيا
الذي تعرض ضد فرنسا
الهزيمه في الغرب الافريقي لها سقط كبير
هناك مطالب كبيره في التحرر من الهيمنه
الاقتصادي التيار
سلطه حاكمه الان تريد ترى مصلحتها في مكان
اخر بعيدا عن فرنسا
سالم تعود تلك الدوله المهيمنه في غرب
افريقيا التي حتميه المصالح ترتبط بها
تتجاوزنا ذلك العهد فرنسا اصبحت دوله شبه
محدوده الوسائل ومحدوده التاثير في غرب
افريقيا صحيح ان هذا لن يتم بين عشيه
وضحاها لكنها في الواقعي اصبحت مطروده من
القاره جميعا من الشمال في السودان
وسط افريقيا ومن الغرب في مالي وفي
بوركينا فاسو الان بالتالي فرنسيه لم تعد
بذلك الوجود ليست فرنسا 1960 طيب حتى في
الثمانينات فرنسا الان هناك انه خمسه
شبابيه سنه قال الموج العاصمه الغرب
الافريقيه هو الولد وجد فيه الوجود
الفرنسي على ارض الواقع تعرفون ان ان الان
فرنسا مضطره الى التعاطي مع سونغو زعيم
المعارضه الذي صرح مرارا وتكرارا ضد فرنسا
هي تاتيه صغيره لتتواضع معه
مع عهودي انها شعارات بانهايم
الخارجيه الفرنسيه
خريسولا زخرفه بولو نائبه وزيره الخارجيه
الفرنسيه نفت خلال زياره لها الى بوركينا
فاسو اتهامات لباريس بالتدخل في
مستعمراتها السابقه
زخروا بولو قالت فرنسا لا تفرض شيئا ولسنا
هنا للتاثير على اي قرار او خيارات معينه
فيما يتعلق ب- بوركينا فاسو سيفتريك
بالنظر الى ما حصل في مالي قبل بوركينا
فاسو بطبعه الحال كيف نفهم المطالب
المتواتره لخروج القوات الفرنسيه من دول
الساحر والغرب الافريقي
من الواضح اليوم وانا اتفق مع الضيف الاخر
افريقيا اليوم لا يمكن ان تقارن بافريقيا
منذ 50 عاما مع وجودي الانترنت
والنخبه الافريقيه العالم متغير اليوم
لذلك الشباب على وجه الخصوص لا يفهمون
الخلفيه وليس
لديهم تالف مع التاريخ
والامور التي حصلت في الماضي طبعا انا لن
اعود الى قصه
العلاقه بين افريقيا وفرنسا في حلوها ولكن
اليوم هذا هو الواقع وهناك عامل اخر اضيفه
الى ما يحصل اليوم وهو
همم الى مفقمه الوضع دور روسيا روسيا تؤدي
دورا من خلال مجموعه فاجنر ومن خلال
التواجدي والتجاره في مالي
وهي المجموعه جاهزه لتدخل في بوركينا فاسو
حتى بالاضافه الى زياره الرسميه التي جرت
من ممثلين بوركينا فاسو الى موسكو
وبالتالي هناك اعاده همم حسابات ضد فرنسا
في القاره الافريقيه يمكننا ان نشاهد من
الدفعه الاخرى ان الحرب في اوكرانيا تؤثر
على الحسابات الروسيه همم ان روسيا تدخلوا
القاره الافريقيه وهي لا تخاطر بالدخول
الى اوروبا وذلك بسبب بوجود خلف شمال
الاطلسي اما في افريقيا في القاره مفتوحه
وهناك الكثير من الفرص بالنسبه الى الروس
مجموعه فاجنر ليست هناك
لتزكيه الوفاق والتعامات
ليه بما انك تحدثت عن عن روسيا لم يعد سرا
بحسب تقارير همم رغبه السلطات في بوركينا
فاسو في تنويع شركات بلادها الدوليه وفي
اولى المؤشرات حديث عن تقارب مع روسيا
بالذات التي قيل ان رئيس الوزراء
البوركينا بيزارها سرا مطلع كانون الاول
ديسمبر المنقضي وبقطع النظر عن صحه ذلك من
عدمه قال رئيس وزراء بوركينا فاسو في لقاء
جماعه بالسفير الروسي مؤخرا ان روسيا هي
خيار المنطق في الديناميه التي تمر بها
البلاد والمنطقه واضاف نفس المسؤول جاسما
اعتقد ان شركتنا مع روسيا يجب ان تتعزز
سيدنا هبه ما الذي يجعل رئيس وزراء
بوركينا فاسو يقول ان التوجه نحو روسيا هو
الخيار الافضل الذي تفرضه الديناميه
الحاليه ما الذي يمكن ان تقدمه روسيا ولم
تقدمه فرنسا
اعيد السؤال بطريقه اخرى ما الذي يجعله
فرنسا تتحكم في سياسه الخارجيه لهذه
البلدان ولهذه المنطقه فرنسا مجرد دوده ذا
التاريخ استعماري والدوله الان ت- تنهب
ثروات هذه البلدان ولا تساعدوا بشكل
الكافي في ضمانها وبالتالي من حقه هذه
الدول من حقه هذه الحكومات من حقي همم
رؤسائها الجدد ان يبحثوا عن بديل عن بديل
عن فرنسا ليس العصر استعمار واهم ما
يبحثون عنه ومن يغيظ هذه التي هكتهم
تاريخيا وواقعيا وبالتالي سيبحثون عن
اغانيها روسيا وبالتالي من الطبيعي جدا ان
تكون روسيا القادمه بقوه الى المنطقه
روسيا التي سيزور وزير خارجيتها الاسبوع
او الاسابيع همم المقبله المنطقه في زياره
هي الاولى من نوعها لموريتانيا والمغرب
ومالي روسيه التي دعمت مالي في الاسبوع
الماضي بعشر طائرات
تقريبا اصبح
اسطوليها الجوي كما في السابق روسيا التي
تخازل بوركينا فاسو وتقدم لها البديل عن
فرنسا عن القوات ال 400 التي تحدث لها
اهلك عن الدعم عن حتى مواجهه همم
جهود فرنسا اقتصاديه
الان هل سيجلب الاستقرار لدول الساحل
الافريقي
وهل كان وهل كانت وهل كانت فرنسا تسعى او
سياسات وفرنسات كاس العالم للاستقرار في
هذه المنطقه ما يحصل من عدم استقرار في
هذه المنطقه انا اسالك عن روسيا طبيعي
فرنسا
للاسف للاسف نحن الان في المنطقه اييه
كالمستجير من الرمضاء بالنار فرنسا لا
يمكن روسيا ليست استقرار ولا لكنها في
الواقعه قد تكون خيارا بديلا لان السياسات
الفرنسيه في المنطقه همم الهيمنه الفرنسيه
في المنطقه اضرعه التاريخ هي التي جنت عدم
الاستقرار هي التي ادت الى سياسه الكيك
بامكيارين اظن ان الحراك الشعبي في
المنطقه الحراك واعي ما زال في بدايته
يتحرر يريد التحرر فعلا من القوى
التاريخيه لكنه واحد بانه لا يمكن ان
يتحرر من هذه القوى بمفرده لابد من سنه
خارجيه وبالتالي في روسيا التي تعتبر فعلا
همم غريما استراتيجيه خاصه في الاستقطاب
بين الغرب والشرق الذي همم الحاصل الان في
هذه بعد الحرب اللي قرانيه الروسيه هل في
هذه التحولات الاستراتيجيه في القاره
الافريقيه ما يفرض مراجعه فرنسا
الاستراتيجيتها في منطقه همم الساحل
الافريقيه بعد كل هذه
يعني الانسحابات اذا صح التعبير الفرنسيه
من المنطقه
ماكرون
قال قبل عيد الميلاد انه اا سوف
يقوم بتقديم مقترحا بعد سته اشهر بحلول
فصل الصيف يقضي باعتماد استراتيجيه وسياسه
جديده
وتتضمن هذه الاستراتيجيا سحابا الى حد ما
من افريقيا طبعا مع الحرب في اوكرانيا
وتاثير الحرب الكبير على اوروبا وعلى
فرنسا بالتحديد ان التواجد العسكري
الفرنسي في افريقيا والذي يقابل ايضا
باتهامات
بمعارضه
والمعارضه المسلحه في بعض الاحيان ان هذا
التواجد لا يؤدي الى نتائج ايجابيه الى
فرنسا ليس من الطبيعي ان تبقى فرنسا هناك
لذلك من المنطقي ان توقف فرنسا
عددا من العمليات هذا هو الاتجاه العام
وبعد ذلك
يجب التقييم الواقع على الشعوب الافريقي
طبعا
[موسيقى]
لدي بعض التساؤلات بنسبه الى دور روسيا هل
يمكن روسيا ان تعيد الازدهار الى افريقيا
على سبيل المثال حيث ان روسيا هي تواجه
مشاكل اقتصاديه جمه
وبالتالي يجب ان نحلل هذه الامور بعد اشهر
ويجب ايضا ان نقول ان الحكومات
في بوركينا فاسو في مالي وفي بلدان اخرى
اذا واجهت انقلابات في هذه البلدان
الافريقيه هل الانظمه السياسيه سوف تكون
اكثر هشاشه هل هناك
شطوره لاحكام القبضه على الحكم في هذه
البلدان اذا كل ما يحصل
يتزامن مع تغيرات عسكريه في البلدان
الافريقيه شكرا ليست التغيرات الديمقراطيه
شكرا
في باريس
والسيد الهيبه ولد الشيخ سيداتي في
نواكشوط شكرا لكما
له تنتهي بالحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
شكرا لحس متابعه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]